today's show is sponsored by vincero
watches which is an american company
building
super premium wrist watches starting at
only about a hundred and fifty dollars
and they're giving you 15 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link underneath
this video today's show
also sponsored by blinkist which is the
app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist totally
free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman that link is underneath the
video as well
yesterday rising republican star daniel
cameron who's the attorney general of
kentucky
announced charges against officers
involved in the fatal shooting
by police of black woman brianna taylor
and very few charges were outlined and
now
protests and unrest are once again
rising and we're going to talk about all
of it as a reminder the story here is of
26 year old brianna taylor
who was killed in her own home when
three
louisville kentucky police officers
executed what's
known as a no knock warrant we've talked
about no knock warrants
many times before um and uh the
the serious concerns about the use of no
knock warrants particularly related to
drug uh crimes this was related to a
drug
investigation daniel cameron said
listen officers did announce themselves
as they executed the no knock warrant
of course the big picture the red alert
is that officers
used this warrant to search briana
taylor's home
for someone who did not live there no
drugs were found in the apartment
and what ultimately transpired is that
brianna taylor's boyfriend
having no idea that it was law
enforcement in their home because
remember there were no drugs there
the person they were looking for wasn't
there briana taylor's boyfriend
started shooting in what he believed was
self-defense from potentially an armed
intruder and brianna taylor ended up
killed
in the gunfight that ensued now one
other note before we outline the charges
yesterday's announcement was about
criminal charges the civil peace
was settled last week the city settled
the lawsuit
against the three officers involved the
lawsuit was brought by briana taylor's
mother
and the city has agreed to pay to meet
tamika palmer
12 million dollars and they've agreed to
enact police reforms
now in terms of the criminal charges one
of the three officers
charged with wanton endangerment
wanton endangerment and that is not
actually related to the death of brianna
taylor
the wanton endangerment is because
of the discharge of the officer's
firearm inside
of the apartment it put neighbors at
risk
that's the charge two other officers who
fired shots
not charged at all so in essence nobody
was charged
for the actual killing of brianna taylor
this has predictably led to significant
unrest
and protests have started and the
protests continue to build and it's
quite possible that the next 24 48 72 96
hours are going to see even more of it
authorities
saying that two officers were shot and
wounded
last night in louisville the interim
louisville police chief robert schroeder
said that they have a suspect in custody
but did not release too many additional
details
we saw demonstrations and marches in
cities including new york chicago
washington dc atlanta philadelphia
just massive crowds we have video of the
crowd in brooklyn near the barclays
center my
sort of old stomping grounds when i
lived in brooklyn that crowd
eventually walked over the manhattan
bridge and connected
with another protest in manhattan um
in chinatown and in surrounding
neighborhoods and we are seeing these
all over the country
in addition to unrest that
did become more violent in louisville
kentucky which is the epicenter of this
case
and again overwhelmingly peaceful
protesters with some provocateurs
uh as as you typically see so there's a
few different
things here let's do the political first
maybe
politically i still think this is bad
for donald trump this unrest
related to racially tinged events is not
good for donald trump now donald trump
and some of his supporters
continue to say these protests are a
preview of joe biden's america
there will be more of this if joe biden
is president i believe
most americans see this and they see it
as part of the failures of the trump
administration
part of the failure of the ideology that
donald trump espouses on police use of
force
and we're seeing it reflected in the
polls we don't really have to wonder
after coronavirus and the economy the
third most important issue right now
is this it's race relations and this
unrest and law enforcement and donald
trump's approval on that issue is very
very low so
i reject the idea that this helps donald
trump more importantly
is the issue of justice we have a
criminal
legal system that is meant to protect
officers now you can debate to
what degree should officers be protected
and i
am the first to tell you that to some
degree they should be protected in the
sense that
being a police officer is a potentially
more dangerous job
than being an accountant or being a
teacher or
being a cashier and so some degree of
protection makes sense
for officers the degree to which
the default is we air on the side of the
benefit of the doubt for the officers
that is allowing justice to not
be served so you know i've given you the
list before
we need demilitarization of police we
need special prosecutors
to investigate police implicit bias
training okay
fixing the war on drugs a bad actor's
database it's a very long list 10 or 12
items which i've outlined
but the precedent that is potentially
set here is horrifying
if you have ever been associated with
anyone who
is potentially a criminal the police can
in certain states issue a no knock
warrant
go into where you're you're you're
living and you can end up shot dead
with essentially no repercussions
defending your home
is not a defense in many of these cases
and remember
there was a grand jury that looked at a
case we covered it
i think i don't know if it was a year or
two years ago at this point
there was a case of a woman who fired a
warning shot
uh to get her husband to her husband was
approaching her and
was abusive she fired a warning shot in
the garage and it hit drywall
she was charged more seriously than
these officers
okay that doesn't make sense so the
system is
hugely failing us we will see the degree
to which
unrest continues in the next few days um
but this is we we've been covering this
for a long time there's nothing new here
but the way in which it is now uh
playing a role
in the presidential election is
certainly something the the timing of
which
um could have political influence and
again i do not believe it will be good
for donald trump
okay there is a a disturbing new piece
in the atlantic by barton gellman called
the election that could break america
this is red alert stuff
this is not a rehearsal okay this piece
explains the plan that the trump
campaign
has put together to bypass
election results if donald trump loses
they
have a plan for how to subvert the
election results
if joe biden were to win and if we
merely ignore it we're not going to be
prepared
so this is really the stuff of
nightmares now i'm going to explain the
idea to you the idea is the following
trump choosing electors in battleground
states
regardless of who wins the state so that
they will vote
for donald trump at the electors
convention
okay this is based on what some call a
technicality
normally the popular vote in a state
determines which electors go to dc
to cast their ballots so if joe biden
wins michigan
pre-selected democratic electors go to
dc and they say michigan pledges our
electoral votes for joe biden
the idea here is even if biden wins
michigan
some republican strategists and lawyers
are saying
even if biden wins michigan donald trump
could say
uh there was fraud in michigan we are
going to send
the republican electors to d.c instead
of the democratic electors
even though supposedly biden won
michigan because i believe that there
was fraud
that's the idea now the immediate
reaction from a normal person would be
how the hell do you justify it and
indeed the justification is fraud
their explanation would be we believe
there was voter fraud
we don't really believe biden won
michigan as an example so because trump
actually won trump is going to select
republican electors to go to dc
and represent michigan the atlantic
explains that quote
trump would ask state legislators to set
aside the popular vote
and exercise their power to choose a
slate of electors directly
the longer trump succeeds in keeping the
vote count in doubt
the more pressure legislators will feel
to act
before the safe harbor deadline expires
a trump campaign legal adviser
spoke to the atlantic for this story and
said that the
goal would be for state legislatures to
say
we've been given this constitutional
power
if they don't think the results of their
state are accurate or if they're willing
to at least suspend
disbelief in order to help trump they
could say
we are overriding the elector choices
and we're sending republican electors to
washington d.c
the chair of the pennsylvania republican
party lawrence tabis
also spoke to the atlantic and said
quote i've mentioned it to them
and i hope they're thinking about it too
referring to this
strategy they are looking at these
strategies this is just one idea we've
talked
you know the more pedestrian and obvious
ideas are
having an army of lawyers descend on
states at midnight on november 3rd well
technically it would be midnight
november 4th at the end of election day
and the idea of the red mirage scenario
would be
because of early in-person voting by
trump voters
at midnight at the end of election day
trump might have a slight lead in some
states
however if all the absentee ballots were
to be counted
those leads might evaporate in favor of
joe biden the idea would be you have
lawyers descend on states
at midnight to say stop counting
absentee ballots
making different legal arguments in
different states
so this is not a joke they are prepared
i've said it before
if trump loses i do believe he will
eventually leave
but here are ways he can try to claim he
didn't actually lose either by
preventing votes from being counted
claiming he won and sending in different
electors
trump's legal teams are laying the
groundwork for all of these strategies
now
we've read that joe biden and the
democratic party
are also lawyering up but are they going
to be ready and
one of the difficulties is when you're
playing offense
you only need to come up with one
strategy the defense isn't prepared for
and deploy it
when you're playing defense you have to
anticipate every strategy in order to be
prepared for it and that's why this is
so dangerous
what if it's simply not definitive come
election day
will julian zelizer who teaches history
and public affairs at princeton
says to the atlantic that quote we are
not prepared for this at all
we talk about it some worry about it and
we imagine what it would be
but few people have actual answers to
what happens
if the machinery of democracy is used to
prevent a legitimate resolution to the
election
our democracy would be dead if trump
succeeds at this
if we fail this is what happens
republicans are making it clear they
don't win by democracy
they will win despite democracy they
will subvert democracy
as david frum said if conservatives
become convinced
that they cannot win democratically they
will abandon conservatism
and they will reject democracy and by
the way
it is not lost on me that this is part
of why they want to rush to replace ruth
bader ginsburg
that could end up being a factor we are
really up against it here
and it is just as appalling how
republican supporters republican voters
are so entrenched in their team sport
mentality
that they by and large are standing by
as donald trump develops these
strategies
as long as they reject the libs right
that's the point
they will accept blatant corruption they
will stand aside
as democratic values not not capital d
lowercase d
democratic values are dismantled and
they will let trump do whatever the hell
he wants
we are up against it my friends let me
know what you think
i'm on twitter at d pacman the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches from
top quality materials and they just look
great i went on their site and picked
out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store
when you go to davidpakman.com vincero
i've put the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
hey y'all consider yourself invited not
just
to get a membership at jointpakman.com
but also to join the discussion on the
david pakman show subreddit
davidpakman.com r-e-d-d-i-t
some uh interesting posts on the david
pakman show subreddit this morning
including one post about listen
the first debate is just days away what
should biden's strategy be
and what will trump's strategy be now
you can read this entire
post on the subreddit but my thoughts
are the following
a joe biden needs to be aggressive joe
biden as you know
has been framed as demented
tired confused beta for lack of a better
term by donald trump while donald trump
has framed himself
as the strong powerful leader
joe biden needs to be prepared not just
on the facts
which are the facts about trump's
failure on coronavirus
the fact about how our economy has
suffered so much more than it had to and
so much more
than other economies thanks to trump's
failings on coronavirus
so biden needs to be prepared on the
facts but biden needs
a strategy where he will be aggressive
and uh donald trump you know he he did
things with hillary clinton
ominously standing behind her and
pointing to her and saying you'd be
locked up if i was president you know
all of this stuff
trump is likely to go for that again and
joe biden needs to be prepared and i
believe joe biden needs to come out
swinging there is very little downside
to it
and he needs to protect himself from
with from what trump's likely strategy
would be trump's
likely strategy is going to be to try
the same stuff that he tried on hillary
on biden and it will be up to biden
uh whether it will work or whether it
will not work trump is likely to come
in with critiques poorly worded and
inarticulate but critiques of
the obama administration biden needs to
be prepared
to immediately rebut that and to say
this is a referendum
on these last four years do people want
you again for another four years and of
course he needs to be prepared uh
to actually have the the factual fight
as well uh
and joe biden needs to be prepared for
the low blows that donald trump is
likely to come in with that includes
hunter biden stuff this includes um
h1n1 seems to be a popular topic for
donald trump this includes
biden and china and biden needs to have
a strategy for how to deal with that so
we'll be covering it live i do think it
will be very very interesting
another post from the subreddit lyme guy
asking do any of you ever get angry
watching the trump movement
i feel like this election is not good
for mental health
uh i i agree i actually agree i am
looking forward to
hopefully the removal of trump and
things being boring for a while it won't
be good for the show financially but i
don't care about that
uh it'll be it'll be better for the
country and it'll be good for our mental
health
and i completely agree and then lastly
user morton posts to the subreddit
it will likely take two to three
elections to undo
some of the damage and i agree and
morton points out that you know our
hopes should not be too high in terms of
what a biden first term would do
i think we need to think about it more
systemically it's not just
a biden first term it's biden winning
democrats may be taking the senate now
maybe in 2022
and it's going to be a cumulative effect
there are things that joe biden can
relatively quickly
undo by executive order there is damage
like including damage to the climate
damage to international alliances which
have been ruined under donald trump
that will take some time and then
remember on the tail end of it we're
still going to have 60 million trumpists
living in the united states
what do we do about that i still don't
have the answer
join the discussion as more than 23 000
of you already have at davidpakman.com
reddit uh people in the audience have
been sending me more and more of these
video clips of
michael shore our great friend michael
shore
uh speaking to trump supporters at
recent rallies as well as other
reporters and i want to play a few of
them and talk a little bit about it
we did a story a few months ago about a
group of um uneducated
white women who voted for trump in 2016
being interviewed on cnn and it was
really bad and i said at the time this
may not be politically correct this may
not be polite
but we have to come to terms with the
reality that many voters have no clue
it's unfortunate it's not nice to say in
these terms maybe but the point is that
they have just as much of a right to
vote as anybody else
and many of them do vote we have to
understand that we now have some
interviews done over the last five or so
days
with various trump supporters at
different events
and it's really bad it's just as bad
before we get to the michael shore clips
let's start with one from cnn cnn asking
trump rally goers over the last few days
why aren't you wearing a mask and it
instantly turns into
wildly debunked conspiracy theories why
are you guys not wearing masks
i have one with me it's my prerogative
but why not wear one to stay safe
i have a hard time understanding people
when they talk so that's why i don't
wear it
but you can hear me right now i can hear
you
why are you not wearing your mask
because there's no covet
it's a it's a fake pandemic created to
destroy the united states of america
but the president said to bob woodward
that there is a virus the coronavirus
and that it is devil
that's his opinion the truth is is that
the cdc said there's
only less than 10 000 people die from
covet the other 190 000
have two 2.6 or 2.8 other mortalities
covid was created to destroy the us
that other conspiracy theory by the way
about you know the real number of deaths
is nine thousand
we've already debunked that it's been
widely debunked but the the mess the
important thing to glean is
even though it was debunked weeks ago
you still have
these rally goers who probably do vote i
mean i think that if you go to a rally
you're almost certainly voting they
still are repeating these
uh conspiracy theories uh and then it
continues now
taking sort of a more religious approach
about not wearing a mask
i'm not afraid the good lord takes care
of me
if i die i die we gotta get this country
moving can't
we do wear masks and stay inside for
another year
huh where will that get it so that's
really bad
then we have these great clips from our
friend michael shore
doing these interviews for tyt and
first folks going right into socialism
he says he's not a socialist but all of
his ideas that sound like socialist
ideas
and everybody around him are like
socialists and they all support that and
he
i think that as soon as he's in office
he will start pushing socialism if he
was in office
they're the devil they got a lot of
satan in them
they're out for their own good they have
no interest in the united states of
america
in the day there who's the they the
democrats
[Music]
biden pelosi all of them uh
they just got a lot of evil in them
they're not in the best interest of the
united states of america
i support trump because he's not a
socialist i'm a foreigner in america
i live in two socialist countries and
i'm on nothing to do with socialism
do you see joe biden as a socialist
the people that are handling him are
socialists yes
there are no socialist ideas from joe
biden
now what's what you know i've said
before
i get criticized for being a socialist
even though i'm not and
for not being a socialist by people who
want me to be a socialist
many on the left wish joe biden were a
socialist
he's not there's nothing socialistic
about joe biden's policies
here our supporters confronted
by michael shore with donald trump's
comments about
soldiers who died in combat being losers
and suckers we suspected that many of
them would simply say trump didn't
really say
it and that's exactly what many of them
said
ridiculous the media all the lies they
put out there are ridiculous
no president is going to make a comment
like that definitely
donald trump our president is not going
to make a comment like that look what
he's done with the veterans he's done
more for their medical care than any
other president probably in the history
of the country
so absolutely false and the media is
going to come out with something
false every day they continue to lie and
lie and lie and
people are a lot of people are aware of
that
if john kelly did say that happen what
would you think of that
i would disregard it because i know
there's over 25 people that said it
didn't occur
doesn't fit with your world view doesn't
match
your pre-existing beliefs well then just
say it didn't happen
here's another one it's all a lie he
loves the veterans
and i i i'd rather have him 10 times in
a head bite
biden won't do nothing but sell our
country to china and anybody else he can
get a dollar from
that's all he's ever done since he's
been in office
uh as as a military veteran some of the
stuff that's come out about what the
president's allegedly said about
uh you know americans and cemeteries and
whatnot and what he said about john
mccain a naval man
has that given you pause at all there
has not um
he has says he has said some things that
you know i see things
off of the spur of moments that i go
back to
what did i say that for you know that
last guy interestingly
taking the approach not of denying that
trump said it but denying that he meant
it
and then this last one is really special
mike michael shore from tyt really doing
a great job on these
um trump supporters asked what will you
do
if donald trump loses will you accept
the result of joe biden wins
no under any circumstance no
why is that because it's
lies and deceit and corruption
so this is one strategy and again this
is the importance
of paying attention to the stories trump
tells
they're ridiculous stories but they work
they stick to people
if biden wins it would be fake
preemptively saying
it'll be fake if biden wins take a look
at this next one i'll be down on my
knees praying a lot harder
praying for joe biden's success or
praying for
uh four years from now replacing joe
biden
praying for god to help us president
biden
that can't happen i can't even think
about that because he does not like
america he's a racist
now that's a racist if you want to look
at someone who
despises the black man the black woman
he
looks out for himself he's a crook his
son is a crook
he's a criminal what happens if donald
trump loses do you have uh a fear
of for the country of donald trump
you're nodding your head i'll go
okay you can evolve i'll ask both of you
we actually have plans to move to panama
because it's a city or it's a country
that allows americans to move there and
to actually own firearms there
i mean if they trust us enough to own
firearms as
you know people with legal right to be
in their country
you know it seems like a place that's
not planning to do something terrible to
their people
but if he wins it means the democratic
machine has won in some of the
illegal tactics that you know the voter
fraud
i i think that if he loses they come
after all of us
supporters yeah biden is actually
the racist now i know the reaction
from many of us when we watch this stuff
when we hear these clips is discussed
how are these our fellow americans how
is it possible to have such uneducated
ignorant people in the united states
this is the result of our education
system
this is the result of religious
indoctrination this is the result of
decades of anti-intellectualism going
back to
i mean you know in a sense
anti-intellectualism has been around for
hundreds of years but
certainly prominently in the republican
party to reagan
and you know this imaginary welfare
queen with 12 kids and
a cadillac and whatever the story was
everything we've been talking about
this is the outcome that we are seeing
we are seeing it front and center
and it is very ugly uh check out one
other one here
i've actually considered leaving the
country moving to south america or
something like that
if something like that happens i've had
neighbors that
moved when hillary is running against
president trump because he was convinced
hillary was going to win he sold
everything and moved to panama so
i'm thinking you know my ancestors did
that back in the 1900s when they left
germany so
i would hurt for my grandchildren why
south america
i wonder most of those governments in
south america are left-wing governments
by most standards
now if the guy likes authoritarians
i guess he could look at moving to
venezuela but
i don't think that's the idea of a
better place
for most trump voters but really really
stunning
stuff and we have to resist
you know there's this thing that will
often happen on the left
where we start kind of moralizing
and talking about you know these poor
stupid people
and blah blah blah blah they vote
and i think that we really need to see
them
it's much more productive to see these
folks as
victims rather than perpetrators they
are victims
of an education system that has failed
they are victims of in some cases
religious indoctrination they are
victims of a lack of media literacy and
a corporate media that thrives
on salaciousness and so on and so forth
it's far more productive to do that than
to look down at them from some moral
high ground which i think
is both unjustified in many ways and
completely counterproductive
let me know your interpretation if you
disagree with mine and we'll have more
of these clips
on the show instagram page at
davidpakmanshow
on instagram the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome will summer back
to the program will is a tech reporter
for the daily beast also
author of the wright richter newsletter
on conservative media
a great person to follow on twitter i
would also say will
uh thanks thanks for being back on hey
thanks for having me
so we've been we've been following and
talking about
uh q anon we've talked with media
matters alex kaplan
about q anon members who have a real
shot at being elected to congress so we
talked about marjorie taylor greene of
georgia colorado's
lauren bober there are others as well
okay
let's first start with with your
assessment of the strength of this as an
actual political movement
um yeah you know i i think humanon is
really getting a foothold within the gop
um we saw a poll this week that said
roughly 40 percent of
republican correspondent respondents
said that
q anon is a good thing um you know we've
seen other polls suggesting maybe around
seven percent of people believe in it
so you know i mean these are not it's
not a majority by any means
but given how crazy their beliefs are
you know it's pretty concerning
is uh i read an interesting article by
greg stanton and we may be speaking to
him at some point in the future
where he points out that q anon
ideology to the extent that we can call
it an ideology
is really like rebranded anti-semitic
tropes that there's a lot of overlap
with
ideas from the protocols of the elders
of zion and just a lot of the standard
tropes of white nationalism and
anti-semitism that we've seen
do you agree and like what what portion
is
is made up of that yeah sure so q and on
it's sort of like scientology where
when people first get into it like they
don't tell you kind of the wildest stuff
so you know people get in and they'll
say like you know don't you think
jeffrey epstein was bad obviously
obviously people do and then they kind
of get you in there and then when you're
really into it they say
well really q anon is about people in
banking in hollywood which
obviously kind of code um drinking
children's blood
so you know i mean you get right into
blood libel right there so you know
this i you know q on really is about you
know alleging all these powerful jewish
people or controlling the world so
um you know pretty anti-semitic on its
face there has been uh
that in the last 48 hours it seems far
less likely that this will happen but
donald trump had been banking
for political reasons on a vaccine
announcement
probably sometime in the next six weeks
which was likely to be an emergency use
authorization not a full approval from
the fda the idea being that he could
sort of attach himself to it and take
credit for it
uh at the same time their q anon seems
to be relatively
anti-vaxxed am i wrong about that so so
i'm i'm
seeing a very strange situation where
trump has previously tweeted about
vaccines and autism
he had to kind of be talked off alleged
by ben carson during debates during the
2016 republican primary
now he's sort of all in on a vaccine and
yet
he this group seems very anti-vaxx
yeah it's an interesting contradiction
um you know as you said trump has kind
of
promoted anti-vaccine stuff in the past
um but now
but in q and on people uh often are very
anti-vaccine
um q or anti-vaccine facebook groups can
be
sort of a a gateway into q anon um and
so
we've seen especially during the
pandemic we've seen interests and q anon
explode
along with a lot of skepticism about
vaccines and now you have trump come out
and say well you know the vaccine is
really key to everything
and so i mean there definitely is a
clash there i mean q1 people have been
saying you know bill gates is going to
put a microchip in the vaccine
yeah and suddenly trump kind of has to
turn these people around on it
when you look at um the
media foothold to the extent that it
exists for q anon
are they uh linked in any way
to any particular media outlets or
publications
and in particular i'm interested about
whether there's a connection with
oan this uh sort of like uh poor man's
fox news
kind of a blend between fox news and and
a porn parody of sorts
um that that donald trump has regularly
called on during his press briefings
yeah you know we see q anon on its face
is so ridiculous
that even conservative media often wants
to distance themselves from it
but what they end up doing is sort of
taking ideas from q and on
and then sort of laundering them taking
stripping the q and on
name off of it and running with it in
the case of oan
initially they were very anti-q anon um
but you know i just had a story this
week that they've been selling the use
of q anon emojis
on their youtube channel uh including
one referring to jfk jr coming back to
life
so you know i mean really there it seems
like they've just decided to start
profiting from it
right on the david pakman show youtube
channel if you subscribe
you get various colored show logos
and yet on oan you get q anon stuff
that's certainly a different approach i
guess to uh to sort of monetizing
content yeah well maybe you should
consider you know
an emoji that's like send hillary to
gitmo all this stuff right i should i
should look at look at that direction
so okay let's zoom out a little bit
because
you're following a lot of these
different movements
what else is there right now that maybe
our audience is not super familiar with
i mean i think my audience is very
familiar with you know kind of your
standard trumpus talking points we've
looked at video from rallies
uh god is protecting me from the virus
or the virus itself is a hoax sort of
that wing which is anything trump says
they they kind of repeat
we've got this q anon wing what other
sort of
subgroups are relevant in the underbelly
right now
yeah well you know i mean obviously
we've got these sort of violent groups
um like the proud boys
or uh the these various kind of militias
that i think are really starting to
merge with q and on in some ways
um and really this is you know
especially relevant as we head into
the election and these people are you
know there's all this kind of civil war
type rhetoric
um and you know i think maybe one of the
most interesting ones um
again with some ties to q and on is the
growth of these conspiracy theories
in like wellness and like yoga like
instagram influencers
i have not heard about this this is
interesting yeah so the typical q a
believer is you know white older kind of
evangelical
um but what we're seeing is there's this
group called save the children
and this is kind of a q anon front group
and they're having rallies with hundreds
of people across the world
in different cities and they're they're
sucking in a lot of
moms on facebook you know cue a mom uh
and you know these various instagram
yoga people who normally post about
you know eating yogurt and doing yoga
and all this stuff and then they'll just
be like
you know but but we got to get to the
bottom of what's going on at comet ping
pong
uh so you know it's disturbing stuff and
i think it suggests that these
conspiracy theories can go beyond just
the trump base
you mentioned the the demographics of
the typical q anon supporter
one of the things we learned about 2016
was that the rate of the dissemination
a re-sharing of fake news was
significantly skewed
not just to the right but to older folks
uh and we could talk about sort of the
the reasons why
q anon seems to have a significant
younger contingent that maybe wasn't
there with some of the
predominant fake news stories of 2016 is
my impression correct
that's absolutely right and you know one
example just to to pick one
is that q anon and tick toc or excuse me
and pizzagate
are exploding on tick tock with young
people and they'll make these tick tock
videos that say like you know here's
something about john podesta
you know and like yeah that now is there
anything that you can
uh ascertain as to why
this is getting more pickup with younger
folks whereas a lot of the 2016 stuff
did not is it just that
the technology now has changed in such a
way or the environment is different or
is it a concerted effort
you know i think it's i think maybe the
biggest part is that the world just
seems like it's gotten a lot crazier
um you know and you have these obviously
you have the very real epstein stuff
that i think pulls people into these
conspiracy theories you know you have
the pandemic
and so i think there's just a lot more
people who are kind of looking to get a
grasp on what's going on and
unfortunately
they kind of fall down these rabbit
holes in uh in 2010
we saw the rise of the tea party
movement and a number of tea party
candidates won
tea party caucus was created in the in
the house of representatives
uh and then eventually the tea party the
caucus still exists
but some of it kind of went away and
some elements were integrated into the
republican party but there was never
the tea party was not associated with a
presidential candidate
in the way that q anon is associated
with trump
so can you outline the likely paths
where you've got
so you have trump and then some q anon
candidates they
they all could win or they all might
lose or some combinations of the two
what's the sort of path forward look
like depending on what happens in
november
sure i mean here's what we're looking at
in terms of like how many q and on
people are going to be in congress next
year
right so we've got marjorie taylor green
in georgia who you mentioned um you know
she's in a really republican district
she's a republican
so she's almost certain to win um you
know trump's endorsed her
the i think it's very interesting that
the the white house has been very
real they just will not criticize q anon
which i think
is another sign of cubanan's power um
you know and in fact when a republican
lawmaker came out and did criticize q
and on the trump campaign attacked him
so you know that's kind of the line is
like don't talk about q anon
and certainly not in a negative way um
we've got lauren bobert in colorado
house candidate kind of a battleground
district she says
well i don't believe in q and on anymore
oh well great you know i mean you know
she said you know i support q and on i
hope it's real and now she's kind of
backed away
um but so she's maybe got a toss-up
chance um
you know in i believe oregon and
uh and delaware there are republican
senate nominees who have
believed in cue and on um they're
probably not going to win
um but still you know out of 35 senate
races we've got two
two uh with q and on believers so you
know
i think the gop is really failing to
stand up to this and so i i think we can
expect to see more of it
to what degree should the democratic
party
engage with this criticize it and and uh
what i mean it you know there's often a
discussion about
uh platforming versus ignoring versus
responsible platforming as some call it
do you have a sense of
whether this has risen to a point at
which we need to hear more from the left
about it
well you know it's really hard to say i
mean as you say on one hand you don't
want maybe joe biden going out every day
and saying
uh you know here's what he went on is
you know because you're exposing a
certain amount of people to it
on the other hand i think certainly when
it comes to the media um you know the
the the cow has left the barn i think in
terms of
not telling people about q and on or
hoping it doesn't get bigger um you know
we're talking about q and on murders q
and on terrorism q and on kidnapping
and you know at some point i do think
you know we have to trust voters and the
audience
uh to know what's going on even you know
even
if it's very crazy if you look around
the uh
if you look around the country and you
see some of the different
groups that i mean my take well maybe
let's let's actually start there to see
if we're on the same page on this piece
my take generally has been that donald
trump has not
really generated new racism or
xenophobia or radicalism
but has made that which already existed
sort of more comfortable being public
about it
question one is do you agree with that
assessment or has has trump's presidency
actually created more of that well you
know
certainly i think uh you know i wouldn't
want to suggest that trump is
you know kind of a unique character in
terms of uh you know racism
uh on the other hand i think in terms of
conspiracy theories i think having a guy
in the white house
who promotes this stuff obviously was a
big birther and legitimizes it i do
think that
uh kind of brings the gop it basically
provides an opening i think for these
conspiracy theories
to take over the gop and get more people
from within
so so i guess the question is if trump
loses are we to expect that a lot of
these
groups whose views are now much more in
the open
are they going to go back underground in
some sense it doesn't eliminate the
views it doesn't
de-radicalize but it would be again an
environment where they are less
comfortable being public about their
views or is the cats sort of out of the
bag at this point
you know it's hard to really predict
what happens um but but i do think that
potentially
if trump loses you know some people are
anticipating you know it's like the
spell lists the q and on people don't
believe in it anymore
i think instead what's going to happen
is that these people who have been so
revved up
and basically convinced that democrats
are like you know eating children and
there's satanists and all this
and that trump's gonna solve it and then
when he loses they're gonna say
well the deep state did it uh now we
have to take matters into our own hands
so you know i i feel like i could see
you really queuing on sort of being
integrated more into the gop potentially
in a violent way
one other thing specifically on the q
anon beliefs i wanted to ask about
a lot of the as you say sometimes the
the gateway to q anon is
jeffrey epstein related the more we know
about epstein the more sort of touch
points there are with donald trump and
there are even allegations that were
made in a lawsuit which have said
the lawsuit has since been been pulled
but they were allegations about
joint sexual assault involving donald
trump and jeffrey epstein
is there no concern in your mind or
discussion among q anon
that the more they push this that it
could actually implicate donald trump
no i mean you know they have so much
like cognitive dissonance and
rationalization
uh when it comes to trump i mean
obviously trump you know appointed the
prosecutor who gave epstein a sweetheart
deal to the cabinet
um you know obviously there's videos of
trump and epstein hanging out kind of
appraising women together yeah um
and so instead what they say is that you
know trump was infiltrating epstein's
circle
and that by uh by appointing this
prosecutor to the cabinet he was kind of
drawing more attention to this dirty
deal and all this kind of stuff
that that's like a textbook example of
the unfalsifiable argument it's
you know there's an invisible tiger in
this room oh all right well
let's you know uh let let's let's lay
down some baby powder so as the
invisible tiger walks around it'll
disturb the baby powder
well no it's also a weightless invisible
tiger like there's no
you cannot possibly uh disabuse someone
of those beliefs and that
maybe that's part maybe that's by design
i guess
absolutely i mean part of the beauty of
the q am clues or the genius of it
is that even when they make predictions
people will say you know the prediction
doesn't come true they'll say
well maybe we just misread the
predictions we were wrong um or that
some maybe q
is trying to throw off the deep state
you know with some bad info
um and so really this makes it really
hard to disabuse people of these notions
um
and you know i hear all the time from
people who have lost family members or
loved ones
uh to q and on and you know it's really
hard to get people out of it
we've been speaking with will summer
tech reporter for the daily beast
also author of the wright richter
newsletter on conservative media
will always great speaking with you
absolutely thanks for having me
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today is uh not a day
like any other and i'm not this i'm not
doing a passover seder i know many of my
friends will will
recognize that line from passover no
today is not a day like any other for
different reasons
yesterday yes donald trump spoke
publicly again
yes we are going to discuss it yes i am
going to play some clips but donald
trump has now gone over a line
where he is just five and a half weeks
away from the election
refusing to say that there will be a
peaceful transition of power
should he lose he will not commit to a
peaceful transition
now when you combine this with our
earlier story from the top of the show
about donald trump's uh contingency plan
for how to retain power even if he loses
you have to at this point start paying
attention this was a press briefing i
guess it was
sort of under the umbrella of a
coronavirus press briefing although
on coronavirus trump says the same thing
every time which is we're doing great
everything's fine on the virus and then
the questions
started from the press corps and donald
trump was asked will you commit
to a peaceful transfer of power and
donald trump
refuses to commit to it and he's a
wannabe dictator and we should all be
very very scared
when loser draw in this election will
you commit here today
for a peaceful trans referral of power
after the election and there has been
rioting in louisville there's been
rioting in many cities across this
country
red and your so-called red and blue
states will you commit to making sure
that there is a peaceful transferal of
power
after the election well we're gonna have
to see what happens you know that i've
been complaining very strongly about
the ballots and the ballots are a
disaster and
but people are rioting do you commit to
making sure that there's a peaceful
transfer
we want to have get rid of the ballots
and you'll have a very trans we'll have
a very peaceful
there won't be a transfer frankly
there'll be a continuation
the ballots are out of control you know
it and you know who knows it better than
anybody else the democrats know it
better than anybody else go ahead
now the guy asking the questions saying
hey but people are rioting so will you
commit to a peaceful transition
it's actually a non-sequitur and and you
know we have protests that are mostly
peaceful
and now there is unrest because of
what's going on with brianna taylor in
kentucky which we already talked about
i don't really love the framing of will
you commit to a peaceful transfer of
power because there are riots it's like
well
hold on will you commit to a peaceful
transfer of power is really the full
question you don't need anything else
with it
but this is the red alert the the
reaction from donald trump we don't have
to speculate
that donald trump might not leave or
will try not to leave to be
to be clear because he's saying it in
broad daylight i have to see the results
first before i commit to a peaceful
transfer of power
even if i lose when trump says
the way it will be peaceful is if we
don't have the ballots he's referring to
vote absentee by mail which trump thinks
would lead to him winning he is
essentially saying
if the results are that i won we will
have a peaceful transition
in that there will be no transition
because if the election is fair i will
win
this is an extraordinarily dangerous
thing to say
uh all standard bullet points apply
everybody has to vote this is not a
rehearsal
this is happening he's doing it it's
outrageous
and uh it it didn't get any less crazy
just a couple of other clips donald
trump was told
during the briefing that prince harry
and meghan markle
will not be supporting him and trump
just insults meghan markle
mr president uh prince harry and meghan
markle uh
chimed in on the us election and
essentially encouraged people to vote
for joe biden
let me get your reaction to that i'm not
a fan of hers
and uh i would say this
and she probably has heard that but uh
i wish a lot of luck to harry
because he's gonna need it this is a
president
speaking this way and then trump brings
up and we'll discuss this later
that mixing the flu with the china virus
as he calls it will be interesting
the flu when it's mixed with kovid
or china virus is going to be very
interesting to see what happens but
interesting is certainly an interesting
way to describe it and then
even the end of this press briefing is
wild trump
abruptly says as the questions start
coming in about briana taylor
trump says he has to go take an
emergency phone call and walks away and
when reporter john roberts asks him
who's the phone call with
trump just says it's very important
leave for an emergency phone call
i'm going to let scott and larry finish
up larry's going to talk about
what he's got so i'll be uh i'll be back
i will see you tomorrow
a big day just one more question on
brianna taylor we're in a time right now
where
americans feel like we are on this
carousel
mr president just one more question
okay so that's just a little bit of the
the
the flavor the tone but the big thing
here is donald trump is refusing to say
he will leave peacefully if he loses the
man has come to the end of the line
and he knows biden could win
biden could win and he is going to pull
out all the stops and see if he can get
away with it and why wouldn't he
he's gotten away with so much so far why
wouldn't he try it
and the ironic thing is we talk about
projection
constantly if biden wins trump will
call that a coup that's what trump will
say
is a coup they will always accuse you
of what they are actually doing now the
truth here
is donald trump has always had this
perspective
what i mean is trump still hasn't
accepted the results of 2016
when he won trump still does not accept
that he really lost to hillary by
millions of votes
he continues to say well i won
electorally hugely
and even on the popular vote it was
rigged
buses from massachusetts to new
hampshire it's like well hold on
what are you talking about how would
that how would that even affect the
popular vote first of all if people are
voting in the wrong state
but in any case he still has not
accepted the results of an election he
won
democracy is really at risk here and
certainly donald trump will do
everything he can not to accept the
results
of an election if he loses okay now one
other thing i want to separate this clip
out from yesterday's press briefing
because it really boggles the mind how
ignorant and clueless
donald trump still is on the basics of
coronavirus
during yesterday's press briefing donald
trump asked
is there a way to separate the flu and
coronavirus
can we distinguish if someone has the
flu
from someone who has coronavirus it's
almost like
trump hasn't spent the last six months
talking about
testing coronavirus testing coronavirus
tests which tell you whether you have
coronavirus
or not this is inconceivable
that this is a question we're still
getting from trump in september
you see what's happening in europe
however they have a very big spike
countries that we thought were doing
well aren't doing well they had some
very big spikes very a very big surge
months ago we increased our nation's
procurement
of the flu vaccine by 66 and we ask
americans to go get their annual flu
shot
as early as possible it's possible i
would imagine
scott that the flu can get mixed up with
the virus and people can think it's the
virus when actually it's another flu
season coming on
i don't know it's uh i hope they can
keep them separate can they keep them
separate
we hope so i definitely will it's
going to be a very interesting time but
we have a flu season coming up we've had
some flu seasons which are
really massive over the years scott do
we have a way of separating a flu case
and a coronavirus case
and even more bizarre i mean it's a gong
show scott atlas bizarrely says
i hope we do and donald trump says i
don't think we do
he spent the last six to seven months
talking about coronavirus tests
testing how many tests how fast are the
tests
he says it all the time when you test
you find cases that's how you separate a
coronavirus case from something else
we have a test for the flu which tells
us if someone has the flu
we have a test for coronavirus which
tells us if someone has coronavirus
how does the president of the united
states not know that at this point it
it's mind-blowing inconceivable
ignorance and
and maybe more important well not more
importantly but
equally interesting is that this is
probably a peak behind the curtain
of how people deal with trump behind the
scenes the normal response if someone
says
hey can we tell the difference between
coronavirus and the flu a normal
response would be absolutely
we have tests for the flu and we have
tests for coronavirus no problem
this is how it works scott atlas instead
says i hope that we can
what and my sense is that this is how it
works behind the scenes frequently we
wonder
trump's been mispronouncing convalescent
plasma
as convalescent plasma for months how
has no one just said oh
you know mr press sir as trump likes to
say sir it's plasma
apparently trump loses his mind when
people do that
we wonder why does trump keep saying the
1917 flu
it's the 1918 flu why has no one gone up
to him and said
it's 1918 not 1917. well scott atlas's
response tells us why
people are either afraid of trump or
they've decided
they can't correct him or it's pointless
to correct him or whatever
but that is probably the explanation
that you saw there
it and it's scary because there is no
error correcting mechanism
in the same way that scott atlas doesn't
just say yes of course
we have flu tests and coronavirus tests
we have to believe
that behind the scenes you see a similar
lack of pushback
on foreign policy on economic policy on
everything
horrifying horrifying and frightening
here's an interesting question that came
in via voicemail
yesterday i interviewed jessie lee
peterson on the program
and a lot of people had some version of
this question take a listen to it
hey david joel in florida i watched your
interview with jessie lee peterson i
wrote
the eclipse where he interviewed you in
the past i've watched some of the clips
of his show
i've looked online uh
my question is is this guy for real is
this sort of like a phil hendry where
he's playing a character or a comedy
routine or is this for real
i'm just wondering what you think about
that yeah so a lot of people have asked
me this i do not believe jesse lee
peterson is playing a character and the
reason i don't believe that
is when i went to his uh studio in los
angeles
he was exactly the same off air now
maybe he's playing
and i'm talking like he's talking about
trump stuff and saying all the same
things
maybe it's such a commitment to the
character that he even continues off air
but i don't think jessie lee peterson is
playing a character which makes it all
the more scary
we've got a great bonus show for you
today one in five recent coronavirus
cases are people in their 20s
people in their 20s we will talk about
the new republican focus on joe biden's
son hunter and we will also talk about
what michael bloomberg did
to enable 32 000 additional floridians
to vote in november
very interesting and important stories
on the bonus show
get instant access instant by becoming a
member
at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's program
was made possible by vincero
watches the american watchmaker building
super quality wrist watches but
making them affordable for everyday
people and they're giving you fifteen
percent off when you go to
davidpakman.com
vincero today's show also sponsored by
blinkist blinkist is the app that lets
you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction
in 15 minutes and you can try blinkist
for free and get 25 off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put that link down
below
underneath the video